the work we have
I know I know
I think I know why you're happy tonight
because them doesn't really add anything
to the whole proceeding no I think I
know what you're happy because the Pope
came to Washington and cast John Boehner
out oh it's so John Boehner us I love
announcements on a Friday we get to get
at it first yes absolutely John Boehner
stepping down as the Speaker of the
House and liberals cheer like that but
you know what don't be so happy this is
the Republican Party it always gets
worse we thought Bush was the worst and
then Sarah Palin came along and then Ted
Cruz and Donald Trump the new speaker is
gonna be you know representative
hillbilly Quasimoto and his platform of
permitting guns and maternity wards and
we're sending the no shirt no shoes in
Congress that's what you're gonna get
next but look you're sweet oh my god did
you watch TV this week all Pope all the
time
po po po po po po I get it the Pope is
here he's doing poping stuff I mean the
last time a guy in a dress got this much
attention it was Caitlyn Jenner
it's like one direction is there people
lining the route of the motorcade were
passing out and that was just from the
fumes from the Volkswagens now people
get very emotional
that didn't stop crying for three days
of course he was an altar boy very
Catholic he's a he's a banners and
dyslexic Catholic
he's always turning wine back into water
but no Boehner was so happy because he's
the guy he's been trying to bring the
Pope you know to America for twenty
years and having done that he said he
had nothing left to accomplish and
that's why he quit I don't know the
cynics say it's really because of pure
politics he lost a battle with the tea
party who oh of course always hated John
Boehner because they said he was slowly
destroying Washington and they wanted
him to pick up the pace
but who knows what's in a man's heart
you know I mean Boehner has always been
terrible on immigrants terrible on the
environment and the ultimate crony
capitalists or the Pope comes to town
and basically shits on everything he
stands for
maybe after hearing Francis speak he
decided to vote his to devote his life
to helping the poor and fighting climate
change yeah he's gonna be a lobbyist for
Volkswagen I promise you that's where
his beauty yeah has nothing to do with
oh no Maybelline discontinued his shade
of bronzer and he had the creds trust me
he's gonna be working for Volkswagen who
I'm sure you know this week that was the
other giant story faking their emissions
test can you believe these bastards and
that Volkswagen today so they conducted
a thorough investigation and they know
who to blame the Jews Joe well I tell
you with all the corporate greed that is
in the news this week the Pope could not
have picked a better time right to come
to this country with his message greed
bad and there is no concealing that the
Conservatives do not like this and do
not like him the three Catholics on the
Supreme Court no-shows at his speech
before Congress I could read you a list
of quotes from Republican politicians
telling the Pope to stick his nose out
of anything that they are doing Michael
Savage the conservative commentator said
the Pope sounds like a false prophet
from revelations
revelations feds I couldn't agree more
compare them to the Antichrist Rush
Limbaugh said he's a Marxist take a
chill pill guys of course thanks to the
wonders of capitalism chill pills are
now seven hundred and fifty dollars and
I tell you this club this Pope has balls
he does not back down when he arrived at
the White House on Wednesday first thing
he said a not-so-subtle dig at the
Republicans he said as the son of an
immigrant family I am happy to be a
guest in your country which was largely
built by immigrant families and that was
I was kind of a mouthful so the
translator just said [ __ ] you Trump and
the Pope was in New York today what a
schedule this guy keeps at the age of 78
a lot of poping he did today started
with an interfaith ceremony at Ground
Zero the Pope was there with a rabbi and
Imam a Hindu a Buddhist and a Sikh and
the Pope was very gracious he said we
may hold different faiths but we are
brought together by the knowledge that
we all believe in some form of utter
nonsense
and then he I lived in New York for five
years I never did all this stuff he went
to the UN he gave a speech he drove
through Central Park he went to a school
in Harlem he gave mass at Madison Square
Garden unbelievable he said the Pope
said the one regret II have is that he
didn't go to the Statue of Liberty
because it would be nice to be able to
say that at least once in his life he
spent some time inside of a woman
you